This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down,
这是一个iHeart播客。真人保证。在Look Back at it播客中。从1979年开始，对我来说那是一个重大的时刻。84年对我来说意义重大。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利什。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析发生的事情，
and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the Outer. My Heart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。与我们的朋友、同为喜剧演员的人以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论80年代。84年是疯狂的一年。真是疯狂的一年。我认为没有比这更重要的一年了，对于黑人来说。在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听Look Back at It。
Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host, Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor it? It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast.
嘿，大家好，你们好吗？欢迎收听 Learn the Hardway，我是你们最喜欢的心理治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖恩斯。这个节目聚焦黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都觉得不太安全进行的坦诚对话，但在这里，你是在和一个懂行的执照专业人士交流。有多少男人背负着西装或盔甲？它向世界释放出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你就必须去这样做。在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听 Learn the Hardway。
In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice in so much, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian, Michael Mancini. My mind was blown.
2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的父亲。但这场怀孕似乎是一场骗局。你在这个特定的测试上做了两次手脚，对吗？我只在测试上动了一次手脚。互联网侦探们出动了一大群人，才揭露出一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格，一个女同性恋者，迈克尔·曼奇尼。我的脑洞大开。
I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange model.
我是斯蒂芬妮·年轻。这是《被困的爱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于迎来了后果。在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听 Love Trapped 播客。2%。这就是当旁边有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人所占的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯顿。在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析心理韧性、健身的科学，以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中培养韧性的方法。
and worry. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world, it is great to have you here back for another episode. Now, this one is pretty special because it is kind of almost a part three from a series that we did a
以及担忧。让自己经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更满足、更健康的人。在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《2%》。即便是TWO percent也一样。大家好，欢迎回到《你二十多岁的心理学》，这是一个探讨我们在二十多岁时经历的一些重大生活变化和转型，以及它们对我们的心理意味着什么的播客。大家好。欢迎回到节目中。欢迎回到本播客。新听众、老听众，无论你身在世界的哪个角落，很高兴你能来到这里收听新的一期节目。现在，这一期非常特别，因为它几乎算是一个系列的第三部分，我们在几周前做过关于
couple of weeks ago on how we can make the most out of our 20s. And if you've listened to that episode, we briefly discussed why it's important to move to a new city during this decade, whether that is in your home country or abroad. And you know what? I really thought that this topic deserved its own entire episode, especially after so many of you have reached out and let me know your experiences, what you'd wished. You'd known, even the goals that you have to do this yourself. There were so many lived experiences, but also questions and, you know, questions for advice that I thought we may as well do it separately. So today, that is this episode. We are going to be unpacking exactly why we feel the urge to sometimes,
如何充分利用我们二十多岁的系列的第三部分。如果你听过那一期节目，我们曾简要讨论过为什么在这十年里搬到一个新城市是很重要的，无论是在你的祖国还是在国外。你知道吗？我真的认为这个话题值得做成一整期节目，尤其是听到了你们许多人主动联系我，分享了你们的经历、你们希望自己早点知道的事，甚至是你们自己想这样做的目标。有那么多的亲身经历，但也有很多问题和寻求建议的疑问，我觉得我们不妨把这一期单独拿出来做。所以今天，就是这一期节目。我们将深入探讨为什么有时我们会有一种冲动，
I would say, upend our lives and just travel halfway across the globe, why there are numerous benefits of this, not just psychologically, but also emotionally and socially. And finally, kind of the big question which is how do we do it? How can we unlock that potential dream that so many of us share? I just want to make a quick disclaimer as well that I totally understand that this is not always an option for everyone because of financial concerns or passports or family and I really do appreciate that. But for those of us who do have the opportunities to consider this, I wanted to really chat through not just some of the practical advice, but also some of the surprise. psychology, like, did you know that there is a literal term for people who cannot stay in one
我想说，彻底颠覆我们的生活，跑到地球的另一端去旅行，为什么这样做有很多好处，不仅在心理上，而且在情感和社交上。最后是那个最大的问题，那就是我们该怎么做？我们如何才能释放那个许多人共同拥有的潜在梦想？我也想做一个简短的声明，我完全理解由于财务问题、护照或家庭原因，这并不总是每个人的选择，我对此非常理解。但对于我们那些有机会考虑这一点的人来说，我想和大家聊聊的不仅是一些实用的建议，还有一些令人惊讶的心理学知识，比如，你知道有一个专门的术语来形容那些无法在一个
place for too long? And there's also, you know, this concept that explains why we kind of get this restless urge in our 20s. It's called novelty seeking behavior. So I think that all of us, including myself, will be very surprised by how much psychology really underpins this very, I would say quintessential 20-something desire. So we're going to discuss all of that and so much more. I also want to really discuss and really explore this idea of a six-month rule. And that essentially says that you need to give any new place you move, wherever that is, six months.
地方呆太久的人吗？你知道吗，还有一个概念解释了为什么我们在二十多岁时会产生这种不安分的冲动。这叫做寻求新奇行为。所以我想我们所有人，包括我自己，都会对心理学在多大程度上支撑了这种我称之为二十多岁典型渴望的心理感到非常惊讶。所以我们将讨论所有这些以及更多内容。我还想深入探讨和真正探索六个月规则这个概念。本质上，这个规则说的是，无论你搬到哪个新地方，你都需要给自己六个月的时间。
You have to really dedicate six months of time, six months of energy, before you can make any further decisions. It takes that amount of time to kind of, establish a community to find your favorite restaurants and coffee spots to get a lay of the land. And I think anecdotally, and from my own life, this hypothesis is very, very accurate. And alongside that, I also really want to explore what are some of the actual behaviors that we can instigate, one of some of the things we can do to make our move a successful one, especially around things like loneliness or fear, those kind of feelings that we are going to bring
你必须真正投入六个月的时间，六个月的精力，然后才能做出任何进一步的决定。需要这么长的时间来建立一个社区，找到你最喜欢的餐馆和咖啡店，摸清当地的情况。我想根据经验，从我自己的生活中来看，这个假设是非常非常准确的。与此同时，我也真的很想探讨一下，我们可以发起哪些实际的行为，有哪些事情我们可以做，来让我们的搬迁取得成功，尤其是围绕孤独或恐惧等问题，这些是我们带到新环境中的感受，但也是那些会拖我们后腿的恐惧。我们如何交朋友？我们如何应对财务焦虑？我们如何找到住处？我们如何才能真正拥抱这个新篇章和新挑战？搬到海外，我认为，是我们在这个年纪能做的最好的事情之一。所以，如果你甚至一直在考虑这个想法，我真心希望这一期节目能说服你下定决心去尝试。正如我们常说的那样，舒适的生活并不总是最好的生活。也许这正是你一直在寻找的挑战，因为你开始觉得现在的处境有点停滞不前或陷入困境。我不知道是不是只有我一个人有这种感觉，但我有一种直觉，这种渴望、无聊、对刺激的需求的感觉，比我们想象的要普遍得多。所以我们有很多内容要讲。我真的对这一期节目感到非常兴奋。再次感谢大家所有的投稿和想法。闲话少说，让我们进入关于二十多岁搬到新城市的背后心理学的探讨。2%。这就是当旁边有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人所占的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯顿。
to a new environment, but also these kinds of fears that are going to hold us back. How can we make friends? How can we navigate dealing with financial anxiety? How can we find a place to live? How can we really come to embrace this new chapter and this new challenge? Moving overseas, I think, is one of the best things that we can do at this age. So if you have even been toying with the idea, I really hope that this episode convinces you to bite the bullet. as we always say, a comfortable life isn't always the best life. And maybe this is kind of the challenge that you have been looking for as you start to feel a little bit stagnant or stuck where you are. I don't know if it's just me feeling this, but I have an intuition that this sensation,
在我自己搬到一个新城市的经历中。搬到海外，我认为，是我们在这个年纪能做的最好的事情之一。所以，如果你甚至一直在考虑这个想法，我真心希望这一期节目能说服你下定决心去采取行动。正如我们常说的那样，舒适的生活并不总是最好的生活。也许这正是你一直在寻找的挑战，因为你开始觉得现在的处境有点停滞不前或陷入困境。我不知道是不是只有我一个人有这种感觉，但我有一种直觉，这种渴望、无聊、对刺激的需求的感觉，比我们想象的要普遍得多。所以我们有很多内容要讲。我真的对这一期节目感到非常兴奋。再次感谢大家所有的投稿和想法。闲话少说，让我们进入关于二十多岁搬到新城市的背后心理学的探讨。2%。这就是当旁边有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人所占的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯顿。
this experience of longing, of boredom of the need for excitement is a lot more common than we think. So we have a lot to get through. I'm really excited for this episode. And thank you again for all of your contributions and ideas. Without further ado, let us get into some of the psychology behind moving to a new city in our 20s. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter.
在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析心理韧性、健身的科学，以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中培养韧性的方法。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等进行对话，看穿那些主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的曾认为种子油本质上会引起炎症。我们搞错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题都是压力的结果。
And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness. and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress.
把自己置于一些艰难困苦之中，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更满足、更健康的人。在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《2%》。即便是TWO percent也一样。任何男人都应该遵守两条黄金规则。规则一，绝对不要去招惹乡下女孩。你玩愚蠢的游戏，就会得到愚蠢的奖品。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side. a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules that any man should live by. Rule one, never mess with a country girl. You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes.
规则二，也绝对不要去招惹她的朋友。我们总是说，相信你的女朋友。我是安娜·辛菲尔德，在《女友们》的这个新季中。天啊，这是同一个人！一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的诈骗犯交往过。我感觉自己像被卡车撞了一样。
And rule two, never mess with her friends either. We always say that trust your girlfriend. I'm Anna Sinfield and in this new season of the girlfriends Oh my God, this is the same man A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist I felt like I got hit by a truck
我心想，这种事怎么会发生在我身上？警察似乎并不在意，所以他们决定自己采取行动。我说，哦，见鬼去吧。我发誓我将成为他的最后一个目标。他会得到他应得的下场。收听《女友们》。相信我，宝贝。
I thought how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care so they take matters into their own hands I said oh hell no I vowed I will be his last target He's gonna get what he deserves Listen to the girlfriends Trust me babe
在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯在VMA颁奖典礼上双击莉莉·金的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟莉莉·金到底有什么关系？嗯，你可以在Look Back at It播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·杰特。我是亚历克斯·英格利什。
on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at It podcast. I'm Sam Jett. And I'm Alex English.
每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。包括最近一集马克·拉蒙特·希尔大谈80年代可卡因的节目。坦白说，84年对我很重要，不仅仅是因为可卡因。我随时都可以聊一聊可卡因，但只是让你们知道。我是说，马克，这是我们讨论可卡因的第二集了，所以我开始看出其中有一条贯穿始终的线索。
Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack all day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack, so I'm starting to see that there's a through line.
我们现在还谈到了艾滋病……谢谢你把这句话说完。是的，我认为对于黑人来说，没有哪一年比这更重要了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的年份之一。在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听Look Back at It。
We also have AIDS on the table right now, so... Thank you for finishing that sentence. Yes, I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years. for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app,
欢迎收听我的新播客《Learn the Hardway》，我是你们的主持人、你们最喜欢的心理治疗师凯尔·盖恩斯。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我带来了我在心理健康领域十多年的经验，以及与许多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。我说的是特里普·方丹、瑞安·克拉克。有时候我们在追求某样东西时，
Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hardway with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing,
我们太沉迷于追逐的过程，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了这件东西，但我们仍然在追逐它，而且我们不知道什么时候才算够，因为人们看着生活的记分牌，生活变成了关于赢和输。史蒂夫·伯恩斯、达斯汀·罗斯。因为你觉得在这个世界上做一个好人很重要，还是你做一个好人是因为你害怕？因为那是两种不同的动机，兄弟。绝对是这样，那是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你真正成为一个好人。加入我，凯尔·盖恩斯，在我的新播客《Learn the Hardway》中，我们一起进行关于疗愈、成长、父爱、压力和目标的真实对话。
we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing and we're still chasing it and we don't know when we've done enough because people scoreboard watch life becomes about wins and losses Steve Burns Dustin Ross because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth or are you a good person because you're afraid because that's two different intentions bro absolutely and that that's two different levels of trust I want you to just really be a good person Join me, Keir Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway.
打开你免费的iHeartRadio应用程序，搜索 Learn the Hardway，立即收听。搬到一个新城市，重塑自我，开辟一种新的未来，甚至是一种充满激情和社区意识的现实，对于我们这些经历过的人来说，是一段极其具有决定性的经历。这也是一个我个人认为极其重要的决定，是我们所有人在一生中至少应该做一次的事情。我敢肯定它不止在一个愿望清单上。它绝对在我的愿望清单上。所以我想原因在于，做出有意识的决定去颠覆你生活中所有正常的一切，这种经历有一种独特的真正变革力量，明知这会让人感到不舒服，有时会很艰难，但内心深处也有一种清醒的认识，从长远来看，这可能是我们回首往事时，将其确定为真正改变一切的决定。根据经验，这是我与之交谈过的无数人的观点，也是无数写信给我的人的观点，他们说，搬到纽约、伦敦、巴塞罗那或加拿大是我人生的开始。这是我做过的最好的决定。
Open your free iHeartRadio app, search Learn the Hardway, and listen now. Moving to a new city, recreating ourselves, paving kind of a new future or even a reality of excitement and community, is such a defining experience for those of us who do it. It's also a decision that I think personally is incredibly important, something that we should all do at least once in our lives. I'm sure it is on more than one bucket list. It's definitely on my own. So I think the reason why is that there is something uniquely really transformative about making the conscious decision to upend everything in your life that is normal, knowing that it will be uncomfortable and that it's going to be hard at times, but also having this. really deep understanding that in the long run, it kind of might be the choice that we look back on and pinpoint as the decision that really changed everything. Anecdotally, this has been the perspective of countless people that I have spoken to, countless others who have written into me and said, you know, moving to New York or London or Barcelona or Canada was the beginning of my life. It was the best decision I've ever made.
这有点像电影里的时刻，对吧？这是一个我们都应得的电影时刻。我今天真正想提出的观点是，基于大量关于我们在这一十年中达到的发展里程碑的心理学，以及我们处于人生旅程的什么阶段，二十多岁绝对是承担这种风险和获得这种经历的最佳时期。我当然有我的理由。我会让你们知道这些理由是什么。我认为首先，二十多岁伴随着最少的外部责任，这些责任是与之后的岁月相关的。我想到的事情比如孩子，甚至是宠物，长期的伴侣，经济责任。
it's kind of a movie moment, right? It's this movie moment that I think we all deserve. And the argument I really want to kind of make today is that based in a lot of the psychology about the developmental milestones we're hitting in this decade, about where we're at in our life journey, our 20s are the absolute best time to take this risk and to have that experience. And I, of course, have my reasons. I'm going to let you know what they are. I think firstly, our 20s are just accompanied by minimal external responsibilities that are associated with lady gears. So I'm thinking things like children, even pets, long-term partners, financial responsibilities
比如抵押贷款，甚至是学习之类的，对吧？我们经常在二十岁出头时勾选掉这些，实际上对我们很多人来说，这段时期在22岁和23岁时就结束了，我们留下了一张有点空白的画布，有点开阔的空间。这样做的好处是，尽管它可能很可怕，但没有什么能阻止我们。除了我们自己之外，几乎没有什么人或很少有人需要我们对他们负责。而这正是追求重大生活改变（比如搬家）的时刻和季节，它不仅是无价的，而且时机恰到好处，对吧？在我们一生中，很少有几次我们可以真正这么说，那就是时机堪称完美。当然，关于为什么我认为这是一个重要选择，背后还有其他一些心理学上的好处。所以，搬到一个新城市在很多方面给系统带来了一点冲击，这成为了我们需要在这十年中经历的许多必要成长的催化剂。所以让我为你们列出其中的几点。首先，我认为在一个新地方感到不舒服的经历，无论持续多久，无疑能让你更好地了解自己。正如我们常说的那样，你生活中唯一稳定的关系就是你和自己的关系。
like mortgages, and even things like study, right? We often tick that off in our early 20s and really for a lot of us, that period comes to an end by 22 and 23. and we're kind of left with a bit of a blank canvas, a bit of open space. And the benefit of that, as scary as it can be, is that there is nothing holding us back. There is very little or very few people, I guess, that we are accountable for other than ourselves. And that is exactly the time and the season in which pursuing a big life change, like moving, is not only invaluable but actually perfect timing, right? There's few times in our lives that I think
所以建立这种独立、自力更生和真正内心认知的基石，我认为这是非常神圣的。这也反映了一个非常关键的里程碑，心理学家埃里克·埃里克森曾谈到过这个里程碑，那就是同一性与角色混乱之间的斗争。这是我们所有人都会在某个阶段经历的时期，通常是在我们二十多岁的时候，在这个时期，我们确实必须靠自己闯出一片天地。并且在某些方面，我们必须反抗我们家庭和父母的思想和传统，以形成我们自己的身份。
we can truly say that, that this is perfect timing. Of course, there are a few other psychological benefits behind why I think this is an important choice. So moving to a new city provides a bit of a shock to the system in many ways, and that acts as a catalyst for a lot of the necessary growth we need to go through in this decade. So let me lay out a few of these things for you. Firstly, I think that experience of being uncomfortable in a new place for however long that last undoubtedly gets you to know yourself better. And as we always say, the only stable relationship in your life is the one you have with yourself.
而一个新城市，我认为距离你所知道的一切有数英里之遥，是一个做这件事的好地方。这是一个真正令人惊叹的地方，可以用来塑造你自己的身份。其次，它提供了一种真正需要我们培养韧性的挑战。我认为韧性是一个我们讨论得还不够的概念。但它确实是从挫折中迅速恢复的能力。
So building that foundation of independence, of self-reliance and true inner knowledge, I think that's really sacred. it also reflects this really key milestone that the psychologist Eric Erickson spoke about, and that is the battle between identity and confusion. This is this kind of period, this milestone we all go through at some stage, normally during our 20s, in which we do have to strike out on our own. And we have to, in some ways, push back against the thinking and the traditions of our families and our parents to form our own identity.
这对于保持良好的心理力量至关重要。在这个剧本中，我们会遇到挫折。比如签证问题，努力找一个租金不是5000万的好地方，结交新朋友。这些经历，这些旅程中的部分，真的让人沮丧，让人恼火。但每次我们成功克服这样一件事时，它都是一个重要的教训和记忆，当未来困难时期来临时，我们能够反思这些记忆。它提供了事后诸葛亮的视角，即一切都会好起来的，我们实际上已经经历了一些可以说是相当困难的事情，并且从另一端走了出来。它还促进了我们所说的成长
And a new city, I think miles away from everything you've ever known is a really great place to do that. It's a really, you know, amazing place to form your own identity. Secondly, it provides kind of a challenge which really requires us to build resilience. And I think resilience is this concept that we don't speak about enough. But it's really the ability to recover quickly from setbacks.
心态与固定心态的对比。这里向你们抛出了所有的心理学术语，但是拥有成长心态的人，他们把成功、智商和能力等事情视为可以通过努力改变和提升的东西。所以当我们遇到失败时，对于一个成长心态的人来说，那不是一件引以为耻的事情，而是一件可以从中学习并加以克服的事情。另一方面，我们有固定心态，拥有这种心态的人真正把智商、成功、运气等事情视为随着时间推移本质上稳定且不可改变的，这意味着他们遇到的挫折和失败或小波折，不是他们真正能够适应的事情。
And that's really crucial for maintaining good mental strength. And we are going to encounter setbacks in this scenario. Things like visa problems, struggling to find a good place to rent that's not $50 million making new friends. And these experiences, these parts of that journey, they're really frustrating, they're annoying. But every time we successfully overcome something like that, it serves as an important lesson and memory that we are able to reflect back on when times are hard in the future. And it provides the hindsight that everything will work out, that we have actually gone through things that are arguably quite difficult and come out on the other side. It also promotes what we would call a growth
所以斯坦福商学院曾做过一项研究。然后又进行了另一项研究，重复并重新创建了由美国国立卫生研究院完成的那项研究，这两项研究都坚定地表明，拥有成长心态确实几乎在生活的每一个维度上都能提升我们的幸福感。这也是当我们让自己经历我们所说的适应性挑战时，我们可以学到的一样东西。所以把自己置于一个你注定会失败的境地是没有意义的。就像如果你明天报名参加超级马拉松，你知道的，200多公里以上，那不是一个适应性的情况。就像你可能无法完成那场跑步一样。但如果你这样做
mindset versus a fixed mindset. Coming at you with all the psychology terms here, but someone with a growth mindset, they kind of view things like success and their intelligence and their abilities as capable of change and capable of improvement through effort. So when we encounter failure is someone with a growth mindset, that is not something to be ashamed of, it is something to be learned from and overcome. On the other hand, we have the fixed mindset and someone with that mindset really views things like intelligence, things like success, things like luck, as inherently stable and unchangeable over time, meaning that the setbacks and the failures they encounter or the hiccups, they're not something that they can really adapt to.
规模较小的事情，比如报名参加5公里长跑、搬到一个新城市或独自进行一次独自旅行，那是一个适应性的情况，在其中你可以教导自己，你会取得成功，你可以克服可能出错的事情，这确实会带来未来更好的态度。为什么我认为这是一次非常宝贵的经历，用来考验我们在二十多岁的年纪以及考验我们的身份和个性的另一个因素是，它自然地真正提高了我们的解决问题能力，但像我们正在谈论的大型搬迁，它真正刺激了自我反思。关于自我意识和自我反思的最大理论之一，是由一位名叫杜沃的心理学家提出的。他所建议的是，在任何给定的时间，
So there was a study done by the Stanford Graduate School of Business. And then another one kind of repeating, recreating that study done by the National Institute of Health, and both of them really firmly showed that having a growth mindset really boosts our happiness almost in every dimension of life. And it's also something that we can learn when we put ourselves through what we would call adaptable challenges. So there's no point putting yourself in a situation where you have to fail. Like if you signed up for an ultra marathon tomorrow, you know, 200 plus kilometers, that is not an adaptable situation. Like you're probably not going to be able to complete that run. But if you do
我们可以是自我专注的，也可以是他人专注的。很多时候，我们专注于外部环境。我们需要满足什么截止日期？我们需要做什么晚饭？我们需要赶上哪些朋友？所有待办事项清单上的那些平凡事情，它们确实有其存在的价值，就像它们对于维持日常生活很重要一样。但它们同时也阻止了那种至关重要的向内聚焦和自我反思。这是一个真正需要问的重要问题。你知道，你上一次真正花一秒钟对你生活中的什么东西实际上在让你快乐进行一番心理盘点或检查是什么时候？谁在让你快乐？你现在走的这条路将带你去哪里？这真的是
something smaller, like sign up for a 5K or move to a new city or go on a solo trip by yourself, that is an adaptable situation in which you can teach yourself that you will be a six. successful, that you can overcome things that might go wrong, and that really leads to this better attitude in the future. Another element of why I think this is a really invaluable experience for kind of testing us in our 20s and testing our identity and our personality is that naturally it really improves our problem-solving skills, but also a big move like the one we're talking about, it really spurs self-reflection. One of the biggest theories around self-awareness and self-reflection, it was presented by the psychologist called Duvow. And what he suggested is that at any given time,
你想去的地方吗？也许还有一些你一直在逃避的更大的存在主义问题。你知道，在接下来的五年里，我想成为谁？我现在可以做出什么决定，让未来的自己感谢我？如果我继续走这条路，也许是一条让我觉得有点无聊或有点停滞不前、没有受到挑战的路，这真的能让我在未来成为最快乐的自己吗？正是这些艰难的问题，我认为几乎内置在我们搬家前必须进行的心理过程中。你知道，当我们考虑我们可能会搬到哪里时，我们真的必须盘点我们未来的愿景是什么。我们的首要任务是什么？什么能让我们真正得到满足，对吧？而且，这种情绪就像
we can be self-focused or other-focused. And a lot of the time, we're focused on our external environment. What deadlines do we need to meet? What do we need to make for dinner? Which friends do we need to catch up with. All of those kind of mundane things on our to-do list, they really have their place, like they're important for maintaining routine. But what they also do is prevent us from that inward focus that's really crucial and that self-reflection. It's an important question to really ask. You know, when was the last time you really took a second to do a bit of a mental inventory or check around what in your life is actually making. you happy? Who is making you happy? Where is the path you're on now taking you? And is that actually
在你的时间线上创造了一个分叉路口，真正改变了你的时间线。随之而来的是，你个性和观点的许多核心要素，因为你将遇到所有这些新奇的体验，正是这些体验将塑造你在这一形成性十年中的面貌。我认为这样做的结果，正如我一直在说的，真的是具有变革性的。最后，我认为搬家的无数好处之一（多得无法一一列举），就是它巩固了那个我们一次又一次说过的深刻哲学。生活并非永远都应该是方便和舒适的。我们在不适中成长。
where you want to be? And maybe there are even some other bigger existential questions you've been avoiding. You know, who do I want to be in the next five years? What decisions can I make now that my future self will thank me for? If I stay on this path, perhaps one in which I feel a little bit bored or a little bit stagnant, maybe not challenged, is that really going to make me, the happiest version of myself in the future. And it's those hard questions that I think are almost built into the mental process that we have to undertake before moving. You know, when we contemplate when we might move to, we really have to take stock of what our vision is moving forward. What are our priorities? What's going to make us truly fulfilled, right? And like, that kind of creates
所以选择最轻松的方式有点违背了初衷，对吧？是的，生活可以是柔软、温柔和和平的，但如果我们不时地不给自己或我们的大脑一个挑战，或者不为它提供新的刺激和体验（比如适应新环境），我们会感到有点受挫。有时我们看到人们变得非常深刻地不满。对他们的生活感到满意。这并不是说搬到一个新城市就能治愈这种不满。那是我们稍后会讨论的事情。但如果现在就是你，你感到焦躁不安，你感到了那种刺痛，那种自发离开的火花。
a fork in the road that really shifts your timeline. And with some of that, you know, a lot of the core elements of your personality and your outlook because you're about to encounter all of these novel experiences and it's those experiences that will shape who you are during this formative decade. And I think the result of that, like I've been saying, is really transformative. And finally, I think one of the other countless benefits, too many to get into, of moving, is that it reinforces that deep philosophy that we have said time and time again. life is not meant to be convenient and comfortable at all times. We really grow from discomfort.
抛下一切，对此有几种解释，甚至有更多的解释说明为什么这种直觉可能是你应该关注的。人类渴望。人类渴望。新体验。在心理学中，这是一种被称为寻求新奇（novelty seeking）或亲新症（neophilia）的现象，针对我们这些为了寻找新体验的刺激（如跳伞或冒险行为）而几乎走向极端的人。基本上，其推理是这样的。新鲜事物、新的记忆、新的环境，它们真的很有趣，但它们也会在我们的大脑中释放多巴胺。它们让我们好奇，鼓励我们去发现更多，它们也提供了非常基础的娱乐。新奇事物通过所有这些元素吸引了我们的注意力。
So choosing what's easiest kind of defeats the purpose, right? Like, yes, life can be soft and gentle and peaceful, but if we don't give ourselves or our minds a challenge every now and then or provide it with new stimuli and experiences like adapting to a new environment, we're going to feel a little bit defeated. And at times we see people become really deeply disdemeanor. satisfied with their lives. And that's not to say that moving to a new city is going to cure that dissatisfaction. That's something we'll talk about a little bit later. But if that's you right now and you're feeling restless, you're feeling that tingle, that kind of spark to spontaneously leave
你更有可能注意到事物并活在当下。这种经历的作用是激活我们大脑的不同区域。这创造了一种非常积极的体验、积极的感觉，这就是为什么在你的生活中想要一些新奇事物、想要一些新东西与幸福之间存在联系，因此也就有了寻求新体验的内在驱动力，尤其是当生活开始变得有点乏味的时候。所以如果你到了那个点，也许你的大脑正试图告诉你的是，我们在这里有点需要一些新东西了，对吧？我们需要一点不同的东西来保持我们的娱乐，因为我们已经从我们当前环境中的东西中榨取了我们所能得到的一切。
everything behind, there are a few explanations for this and even more behind why this gut instinct might be the one that you should be paying attention to. Humans crave. Humans crave. new experiences. In psychology, it's this phenomenon called novelty seeking or neophilia for those of us who go to almost extremes to find the thrill of new experiences like skydiving or risk-taking behavior. Basically, the reasoning is this. New things, new memories, new environments, they're really interesting, but also they release dopamine in our brains. They make us curious and they encourage us to kind of find out more and they also just provide very basic entertainment. Novel things through all of those kind of elements capture our attention.
其中一部分可能是你需要改变一下日常常规。有很多较小的微习惯我们可以带入我们的日常生活中。但像新城市这样的大跳跃或改变确实为你的大脑提供了所有这些以及更多。我认为另一个因素是，为什么我们很多二十多岁的人特别被移居海外或任何地方的想法所吸引，那就是浪漫。我指的不仅仅是那种卿卿我我的意义上的浪漫，而是更多意义上的文学情感上的浪漫，新城市的浪漫，下雨天、新酒吧和新人们的浪漫。我们都想要那种人们可以在我们80岁时向我们询问的生活故事，我们可以用诸如我们在加拿大生活过的那段时光来给他们一个惊喜。
You are more likely to notice things and be present. And what that experience does is it activates different regions of our brain. And that creates a really positive experience, a positive feeling, which is why there is a connection between wanting some novelty in your life, wanting something new and happiness, and therefore that innate drive to seek out new experiences, especially when life starts to feel a little bit boring. So if you're at that point, maybe what your brain is trying to tell you is we kind of need something new here, right? We need something a little bit different to keep us entertained because we've kind of taken all that we can
或者我们在尼泊尔住了六个月。我想我们所有人对我们希望生活如何发展都有一个非常理想化、充满魅力的故事情节，而且，有什么比在一个陌生的城市里了解自己并拥有所有那些成长故事更梦幻、在某种程度上更神秘的呢？我认为这也真正反映了那种对冒险的驱动力，不仅是对新奇的驱动力，也是对新鲜感、风险和意想不到的惊喜的驱动力。你知道，人类是讲故事的人，我们需要好的故事来讲述，尤其是在我们二十多岁的时候，我们有点年轻、疯狂、混乱和自由。但当然这里有一个我们需要问自己的问题。
from what's in our current environment. And parts of that might be you need to kind of switch up routine. There are a lot of smaller micro habits that we can bring into our daily lives. But a big jump or a change like a new city really kind of provides your brain with all of that and more. I think another element as to why a lot of us in our 20s are particularly attracted to the idea of moving overseas or anywhere really is the romance. And I'm not just talking romance in the lovey-dovey sense, but romance in more of like a literary emotional sense, the romance of a new city of, you know, rainy days and new bars and new people. We all want that kind of life story that people can ask us about 80 and we can surprise them with like the time we lived in Canada
搬家真的能让我们更快乐吗？我们真的能说走就走，把生活转移到一个新城市，然后把我们所有的麻烦都抛在脑后吗？太搞笑的是，我前几天发了一个关于这个的视频。其中一条评论是有人非常友善地警告我，搬家并不能让我更快乐。他们说我真正表达的其实是一种忽视或逃避我问题的冲动。但我认为，如果你面临的问题是你的生活有点无聊，而你渴望一个新的开始，搬到一个新城市并不是一种分心。它是解决方案的一部分。
or we took six months to live in Nepal. I think we all have this very idealized, glamorous storyline of how we want our life to be and kind of, what's more dreamy and in some ways mysterious than, you know, learning who you are and having all of those coming of age stories in a foreign city. It also really, I think, reflects that drive for adventure, that drive not only for novelty, but also for kind of freshness and risk and unexpected surprises. You know, humans are storytellers and we want good stories to tell, especially when we're in our 20s and we're kind of young and wild and chaotic and free. But of course here is the question we need to ask ourselves.
并不是所有事情，作为一个运行心理学播客的人来说，都需要被病理化为一个问题。并不是每一个欲望都是某种不健康应对机制的投影。有时你只想做。做某件事是因为你想做。但回到那个问题，它会让我们快乐吗？其实已经有一些关于这方面的研究了。和往常一样，科学有答案。主要有两种思想学派。一个思想学派说，是的，搬到一个新城市可以说是人们重新校准幸福感所需的完美、全新的开始。另一个阵营则认为，虽然搬家可能会给我们提供一个暂时的、
Will moving actually make us happier? Can we really just get up, shift our lives to a new city and leave all of our problems behind? And it's so funny because I posted a video about this the other day. And one of the comments was someone essentially warning me very kindly that moving wasn't going to make me happier. And that really what I was expressing was kind of like a compulsion to ignore or avoid my problems. But I think if the issue you're facing is that your life is just a bit boring and you're craving a new beginning, moving to a new city isn't a distraction. It's part of the solution.
解决办法，情绪上的暂时提升。在一些研究中，他们发现我们的幸福感最终会在一段时间后恢复到我们搬家前的基准线。所以据假设，当我们不断追逐那种感觉时，我们不断渴望新奇和新鲜感，有时我们会陷入永远不在一个地方呆太久的陷阱。所以这些人就是我们所说的连续搬家者，你那个从不在一个地方呆太久的朋友，那个永远无法对他们称之为家的地方做出承诺的朋友。我想这很罕见，但一些治疗师已经确定，这种行为模式，这种非常频繁的连续搬家，可能是一种防御策略，我们在其中寻求外部环境的变化，来改变本质上
Not everything, you know, speaking as someone who runs a psychology podcast needs to kind of be pathologized into being a problem. Not every desire is a projection of some unhealthy coping mechanism. Sometimes you just want to do it. something because you want to do it. But returning to that question, will it make us happy? There's actually been some research on this. As always, science has the answers. And there are really two main schools of thought. One school of thought says yes, moving to a new city is kind of the perfect, fresh start that people need to recalibrate their happiness. And the other camp, it says that whilst moving might provide us with, you know, a temporary, fix a temporary,
内部的问题。所以我觉得值得提醒自己的是，无论我们搬多少次家，你其实还是把你自己带上了。而且，你知道，我觉得如果配上一杯意大利开胃酒（aperol spritz），我的问题看起来会好很多。或者，你知道，当我在瑞士阿尔卑斯山散步时，会更容易处理，对吧？我真正想说的是，环境的改变带来了视角，而不仅仅是分心。所以我现在想谈谈我们正在面临的这个问题的另一个维度，或者我们正在寻找的这种冲动，那就是我们会遇到哪些困难？诸如恐惧、焦虑、建立新社区、孤独、找到自己的位置之类的事情。我想这些都是伴随着这一切而来的。
lift in our mood. In some studies, what they've seen is that our happiness eventually returns to its baseline, you know, before we moved after a little while. So it's hypothesized that when we keep chasing that feeling, we keep craving novelty and newness, sometimes we fall into the trap of never staying one place for long. So these are the people that we would call the serial movers, that friend of yours who is never in one place for very long, who can never have that commitment to the place they call home. And it's really rare, I would imagine, but some therapists have identified that this pattern of behavior, this really frequent serial moving, is perhaps a defensive strategy in which we seek external change in our environment to change what is essentially
这都是我们会遇到的事情。但我真正要概述的是我搬到一个新城市时遵循的六个月规则。以及安顿下来并充分利用你的新家、这个你最终会称之为家的新地方的一些最佳技巧。所有这些以及更多内容，马上回来。2%。这就是当旁边有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人所占的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯顿，在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析心理韧性、健身的科学，以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中培养韧性的方法。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等进行对话，看穿那些主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的曾认为种子油本质上会引起炎症。
an internal problem. So I think it's worth reminding ourselves that no matter how much we move, you do still take yourself with you. But also, you know, I think my problems would look a lot better with an apparel spritz in Italy. Or, you know, it would be a lot easier to manage when I'm walking in the Swiss Alps, right? What I'm really getting at is that environmental change, it brings perspective, not just distraction. So what I want to talk about now is another dimension of this question that we're facing or this urge that we're looking at, which is what are some of the difficulties that we are going to encounter? Things like fear, things like anxiety, building new community, loneliness, you know, finding your place. I think they all come with the territory.
我们搞错了。我们在市场上感到恐慌的许多问题都是压力的结果。把自己置于一些艰难困苦之中，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更满足、更健康的人。在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《2%》。即便是TWO percent也一样。任何男人都应该遵守两条黄金规则。规则一，绝对不要去招惹乡下女孩。你玩愚蠢的游戏，就会得到愚蠢的奖品。规则二，也绝对不要去招惹她的朋友。我们总是说，相信你的女朋友。我是安娜·辛菲尔德。在这个新赛季中，的女友们。
It's all something that we're going to encounter. But really what I'm going to outline is my six month rule that I have when I move to a new city. And also some of the best tips for settling in and making the most out of kind of your new home, out of this new place that you will eventually call home. All of that and more in just a second. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory.
天啊，这是同一个人！一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的诈骗犯交往过。我感觉自己像被卡车撞了一样。
We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier, person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules that any man should live by. Rule one, never mess with a country girl. You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And rule two, never mess with her friends either. We always say that trust your girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield. And in this new season, of the girlfriends.
我心想，这种事怎么会发生在我身上？警察似乎并不在意，所以他们决定自己采取行动。我说，哦，见鬼去吧。我发誓我将成为他的最后一个目标。
Oh my God, this is the same man. A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck. I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care. So they take matters into their own hands. I said, oh, hell no. I vowed I will be his last target.
他会得到他应得的下场。收听《女友们》。相信我，宝贝。在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯在VMA颁奖典礼上双击莉莉·金的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟莉莉·金到底有什么关系？嗯，你可以在Look
He's going to get what he deserves. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your question. cost. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look
Back at It播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利什。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。包括最近一集马克·拉蒙特·希尔大谈80年代可卡因的节目。坦白说，84年对我来说很重要，不仅仅是因为可卡因。我随时都可以聊一聊可卡因，但只是让你们知道。我是说，此时此刻，这是我们讨论可卡因的第二集了，所以我开始看出其中有一条贯穿始终的线索。我们现在还把艾滋病摆到了台面上。
Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84's big to me, me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now.
欢迎收听Back at it播客。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利什。每期节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。其中包括最近的一期节目，马克·拉蒙特·希尔滔滔不绝地谈论80年代的快克可卡因。需要澄清的是，对我和我而言，84年意义重大，不仅仅是因为快克。我随时都可以聊聊快克，但只是想让大家知道。我的意思是，此时此刻，这是我们第二次讨论快克。所以我开始看出其中有一条贯穿始终的主线。我们现在也正在讨论艾滋病。
Thank you finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hardway with me, your host, and your favorite
谢谢你把那句话说完。是的。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的一年了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的一年。欢迎在iHeart Radio app、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听 Look Back at It。欢迎来到我的新播客《The Hard Way》，我是你的主持人，也是你最喜欢的
therapist, Keer Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross,
治疗师 Keer Games。值此心理健康意识月之际，我将我十多年在心理健康领域的经验，以及与众多杰出嘉宾的对话带给大家。我说的是 Tripp Fontaine、Ryan Clark。有时，我们在追求某样东西时，会太过于沉迷于追逐本身，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了它。而我们还在继续追逐。我们不知道什么时候才算足够。因为人们总是在看记分牌。生活成了胜负之争。Steve Burns、Dustin Ross，
because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth? Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines,
因为你觉得在这世上做个好人很重要？你做个好人是因为你害怕吗？因为这是两种不同的动机，兄弟。绝对是的。这是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你纯粹只是因为想做个好人。加入我，Kear Gaines，
as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, learn the hard way. Open your free, our heart radio app, Search learn the hard way and listen now. I think there's really a perfect time to make a big life change like choosing to move to a new city. And if we're always searching for reasons why we shouldn't do something, you know, maybe you have a partner that you don't want to leave behind or do long distance with or a really good group of friends. If you're always looking for those reasons, you'll always find that there is something stopping you.
在我的新播客《The Hard Way》中，我们进行关于疗愈、成长、父爱、压力和目标的真实对话。打开你免费的iHeart Radio app，搜索 Learn the Hard Way 并立即收听。我认为，做出重大生活改变（比如选择搬到一个新城市）其实并没有什么所谓的完美时机。如果我们总是寻找不该这样做的理由，你知道的，也许你有一个不想抛下或不想进行异地恋的伴侣，或者有一群非常好的朋友。如果你总是寻找这些理由，你总会发现有什么东西在阻碍你。
But I think the philosophy that I want us to take, and I'm sure it's a common one, is that you don't want to look back in 50 years and realize that you could have had a completely different life if you've just taken a bit of a risk. Regret really comes from that dark realization that there is nothing that we can do to change the past. So we really need to act with our future selves in mind when making these decisions. So although we've spoken about all the benefits, another element of it is that sometimes we can be frozen by fear, kind of almost playing this tug of war with these two desires. Do we stay
但我认为我们应该秉持的理念，而且这肯定也是个很普遍的理念，那就是你绝不希望在50年後回首往事时，才意识到如果你当初冒一点险，人生本可以完全不同。遗憾往往源于那种痛苦的觉悟：无论我们做什么，都无法改变过去。因此，在做出这些决定时，我们真的需要考虑到未来的自己并付诸行动。所以，尽管我们讨论了所有的好处，但另一个因素是，有时我们会被恐惧所凝固，几乎在两种欲望之间进行着拔河。我们是留下
or do we go? And there's a lot of things that are underpinning this. It's very natural to feel anxiety and fear at the precipice of a big life change, potentially as well, one that's going to upend one of our core human needs, the need for security. And what it often comes down to is that fear of the unknown. Humans as a species are really bad at dealing with uncertainty. And so we like to create our own hypotheticals or visions of what could come next, kind of in order to provide us with a sense of comfort that we can not only predict the future, but plan for it. And often these ideas or things that we concoct, they're a lot more negative than what will actually happen in reality. For example, you know, catastrophizing and thinking,
还是离开？这背后有很多支撑因素。在面临重大生活改变的边缘感到焦虑和恐惧是非常自然的，这甚至可能会颠覆我们的核心人类需求之一——对安全感的需求。而这通常归结为对未知的恐惧。人类作为一个物种，很不擅长应对不确定性。因此，我们喜欢创造自己的假设或对接下来可能发生的事情的构想，以此来给我们一种安全感，让我们不仅能预测未来，还能为之规划。通常，这些想法或我们凭空捏造的事情，要比现实中实际发生的事情负面得多。例如，你知道的，灾难化思维，认为，
well, when I get there, I won't have any friends and I'll be so terribly lonely. and I'll never find anyone like me. I'll never find community, so I should just stay where I am. In that instance, a negative uncertainty bias is impacting your decision-making. And what it's trying to do is scare you out of pushing yourself beyond your comfort zone. It's kind of ironic how our minds really crave two things at once.
嗯，当我到那儿时，我不会有任何朋友，我会感到无比孤独。我永远找不到像我这样的人。我永远找不到社群，所以我应该留在原地。在这种情况下，消极的不确定性偏见正在影响你的决策。它试图吓唬你，让你不敢突破舒适区。我们的内心真的很渴望同时得到两样东西，这真是挺讽刺的。
They crave the novelty and the new experiences, but also what is comfortable and secure. But I think by recognizing that your brain is likely to be in that kind of automatic state of negativity bias, you're actually better able to distance yourself from those thoughts and think more rationally and also positively, not just about your current situation, but also about the future. Additionally, I think major life changes can cause a lot of stress for us, particularly us people who feel a lot more comfortable in a routine. and even for those who like a little bit of risk, a little bit of trouble, it's still going to present its challenges.
它们渴望新鲜感和新体验，但也渴望舒适和安全。但我认为，只要认识到你的大脑很可能处于那种消极偏见的自动状态，你实际上就更能让自己与这些想法保持距离，从而更理性、更积极地思考——不仅是针对你目前的处境，也是针对未来。此外，我认为重大生活变故会给我们带来很大的压力，尤其是对我们这些在常规生活中感到更舒适的人来说。甚至对于那些喜欢一点冒险、一点麻烦的人来说，它依然会带来挑战。
I think what's interesting to note here is that the brain actually tends to deal with all types of stressful, major life changes in the same way. So we typically think of certain life events like the death of a family member or graduating university as things that are quite stressful, right? Those are things that we really recognize as being a little bit scary and almost coming with a bit of grief. But things that are also seemingly positive like celebrating a new marriage or moving, they can also prompt the brain to react with unease and discomfort. That's because these experiences, good or bad, however we appraised them, they go against our sense of normalcy and the consistency that our brain expects. So it acts with an alarm.
我认为这里值得注意的是，大脑实际上往往以相同的方式处理所有类型的压力重重的重大生活变故。因此，我们通常认为某些生活事件（如家庭成员去世或大学毕业）是压力很大的事情，对吧？那些是我们真正认识到有点可怕、几乎伴随着一些悲伤的事情。但那些看似积极的事情，比如庆祝新婚或搬家，也会促使大脑做出不安和不舒服的反应。这是因为这些经历，无论好坏，无论我们如何评估它们，都违背了我们的常态感以及大脑所期望的一致性。因此它会发出警报。
It responds in a state of panic in order to really make sure that we are processing whether this new environment or this new experience actually poses a threat. Importantly, that is going to go away eventually with time. And when we begin to realize that this new thing, this new experience, this new situation, it's not as scary as it needs to be. And here is really where I want to introduce the idea of the six-month rule that I've already spoken on a little bit. So I've moved a few times in my life.
它会以恐慌状态作出反应，以确保我们切实评估这个新环境或新体验是否真的构成了威胁。重要的是，随着时间的推移，这种感觉最终会消失。当我们开始意识到这个新事物、这个新体验、这个新局势并不像想象中那么可怕时，情况就会改变。在这里，我真正想引入的是我之前已经讲过一点的“六个月规则”的概念。我在生活中搬过几次家。
I moved to Canberra from Melbourne for university. And then most recently, from Canberra to Sydney, which I think was a much more significant transition for me given I did not have the structure of a college or a university environment. And if you listen to my life update on Tuesday, you'll know there is the potential also for another big move in the future. From experience, I've realized that when you move to a new place, it is going to take about six months to feel settled. Just like it takes a few months to adjust to a new job or a new relationship. And in those first six months, you cannot make any drastic decisions. You cannot
为了上大学，我从墨尔本搬到了堪培拉。最近的一次，是从堪培拉搬到悉尼，考虑到当时没有大学校园环境的那种结构支撑，我认为这对我的转变要大得多。如果你听了我周二的生活更新，你就会知道未来可能还会有另一次大搬迁。根据经验，我意识到当你搬到一个新地方时，大约需要六个月的时间才能安定下来。就像适应一份新工作或一段新恋情需要几个月时间一样。在最初的六个月里，你不能做出任何激进的决定。你不能
let yourself move back home. You cannot let yourself almost give up on the dream because it's going to take that amount of time to fully realize the potential of this new place and actually build some of those core needs, things like community, things like a sense of security, things like a sense of place. And let me tell you from personal experience, it is like clockwork. That six month mark comes around and suddenly you kind of look up and you feel like you have people you can call on. You know the best local spots. You have your old haunts. The kind of public transport is down pat. And now this is not a scientific theory. Let me really state that clearly. It is very much anecdotal. But I think the reason that this timeline fits this situation so well is because
让自己搬回老家。你不能让自己对梦想轻言放弃，因为需要这么长的时间才能充分发挥这个新地方的潜能，并真正建立起核心需求——比如社群感、安全感、归属感。我以亲身经历告诉你们，这就像钟表一样准时。六个月的期限一到，突然之间你抬头一看，就会觉得你有了可以随叫随到的人。你知道当地最好的地方。你有你的老地方。公共交通已经轻车熟路了。现在，这不是什么科学理论。我必须明确指出这一点。它很大程度上只是经验之谈。但我认为这个时间线之所以如此契合这种情况，是因为
the first couple of months are going to feel really exciting and romantic and novel. You know, you really haven't had the time to process the change. So it probably just feels like a really long holiday. And the next few months, those are about adjustment. And that is when the homesickness, the dislocation, and the loneliness can really take hold. But then we integrate and we adapt. As humans do, we are very adaptable people. So when we give ourselves the opportunity to find solutions, what we find is that we reach that six-month mark and we feel really secure and we feel like we've done the work.
最初的几个月会让人觉得非常兴奋、浪漫而新奇。你知道的，你根本没有时间去消化这种改变，所以它可能感觉只是一场漫长的假期。接下来的几个月，则是关于适应。那是思乡之情、颠沛流离感和孤独感真正占据上风的时候。但随后我们会进行融合和适应。正如人类所做的那样，我们是适应能力极强的群体。因此，当我们给自己机会去寻找解决方案时，我们会发现当我们达到六个月大关时，我们感到非常安全，并且觉得我们已经付出了努力。
There are a couple of things that we're likely to encounter during those first few months that I want to discuss. Not to kind of make you scared, but just to kind of prepare us all with the idea of what moving actually entails and to get kind of the best information possible. As someone who has done this before, who was planning on doing it again, maybe you can, I don't know, take something from my experience and feel a little bit less scared, a bit more prepared to make this choice. So the number one thing that I think we need to consider has to do with our social relationships and our sense of community. And I think two critical experiences that most likely will occur, but also come hand in hand, is that firstly we will experience kind of a shedding of old relationships.
我想讨论一下，我们在头几个月可能会遇到的一些情况。不是为了吓唬大家，而是为了让我们对搬家实际涉及的事情有一个心理准备，并获得尽可能最佳的信息。作为一个经历过这一切、并且正计划再次经历的人，也许你可以，我不知道，从我的经历中汲取一些经验，感到不那么害怕，对做出这个选择更有准备。所以，我认为我们需要考虑的第一件事与我们的社会关系和社群感有关。我认为最有可能发生、而且往往双管齐下的两个关键经历是：首先，我们会经历旧关系的剥离。
And number two, it's likely that we're going to feel a little bit lonely at time. So let's tackle that first one. There are a number of relationships, particularly friendships, that we sustain because they are convenient or out of a sense of obligation. When we move to a new city, we really separate the true friends from maybe the ones who are just there for the season or the moment maybe, because that distance will put a strain on a connection, however strong it may be. And it also really minimizes that proximity factor that we know is important in friendships being close. You know, when I moved to Sydney, I think my friendship circle shrunk by about half. There are people who I would see really frequently back in Canberra who I really haven't spoken to since I left. And that is absolutely fine.
第二，我们很可能会在一段时间内感到有点孤独。让我们先来谈谈第一点。有许多关系，尤其是友谊，我们维持它们只是因为图方便或者出于一种责任感。当我们搬到一个新城市时，我们真的能把真正的那些朋友，和那些可能只是陪你走过某个季节或某个时刻的朋友区分开来，因为这种距离会对连接造成压力，无论这个连接原本有多强。而且它也确实最大限度地减少了我们所知道的对维持亲密友谊很重要的“邻近因素”。你知道的，当我搬到悉尼时，我的朋友圈缩小了大约一半。有些在堪培拉时经常见面的人，自从我离开后就再也没有说过话。这完全没问题。
You know, the distance kind of separated us. We realized that what it really was was convenience and proximity that was keeping us together. and it may feel really scary at first. Like, you've kind of suddenly lost all of those connections. But I really think that's a natural part of our emotional and our social development in our 20s anyways. Everyone is going to go through it even if they decide to not make a change like this. Sometimes we need to shed some of those excess connections.
你知道的，距离把我们隔开了。我们意识到，把我们维系在一起的真正原因其实是便利和地域上的接近。起初这可能会让人觉得很可怕。就像你突然失去了所有的联系。但我真的认为，这无论如何都是我们二十多岁时情感和社会发展中很自然的一部分。每个人都会经历这个过程，哪怕他们决定不做这样的改变。有时我们确实需要剥离一些过剩的联系。
What will become apparent, though, are the people who want to stay in your life. And I also found that to be a massive experience, the people who wanted to see you, who call you regularly, who plan trips back and forth, who just send those little, I'm thinking of you messages. Those are such strong friendships. And I think when I moved, it really gave me so much comfort that I really had made the right decision that the people who really meant the most to me would stay. You know, distance in this situation does not mean goodbye. But often when we see those relationships dropping off, we can be met with a profound sense of loneliness.
不过，显现出来的是那些真正想留在你生命里的人。我也发现这是一次巨大的体验：那些想见你、经常给你打电话、来回安排行程、只是发那些“我想你”的小信息的人。这些都是非常坚固的友谊。我想当我搬家时，这真的给了我极大的安慰，让我确信自己做出了正确的决定，那些对我最重要的人会留下来。你知道的，在这种情况下，距离并不意味着再见。但通常当我们看到这些关系淡出时，我们会遭遇一种深切的孤独感。
And loneliness is not a dangerous feeling. I want us to remember that. It's merely our brain telling us that it's time to reconnect the same way that we feel hungry or we feel cold. However, I think when we feel like there's no way of doing that, that is when we can feel most lost. Listen, you're going to feel lonely every now and again. Slowly but surely, though, you will meet new people and you will build that community around you. And I have a few tips as to how we can do that. Number one, ask your friends if they have any mutuals in the city that would be open to kind of meeting you. You know, often that's the easiest way to find new people is through existing connections and relationships. Because if you like your friends, which I'm assuming you do, chances are you're going
孤独并不是一种危险的感觉。我希望大家记住这一点。它只是我们的大脑在告诉我们是时候重新建立联系了，就像我们感到饥饿或寒冷一样。然而，我认为当我们觉得没有办法做到这一点时，那才是我们感到最迷茫的时候。听着，你偶尔会感到孤独。不过，慢慢地，你一定会遇到新的人，并建立起围绕你的社群。我有一些关于我们如何做到这一点的建议。第一，问问你的朋友，他们在那个城市有没有什么共同的朋友，是愿意结识新人的。你知道的，通常寻找新朋友最简单的方法就是通过现有的连接和关系。因为如果你喜欢你的朋友（我假设你确实喜欢），那你有很大的概率也会
to like their friends as well. And, you know, kind of bonus points if they also know someone who is also just moved because they'll also be looking out for friends as well. Number two is to join a local social sporting group. Easy made friends. You see them once a week. You can go and get beers after. You socialize and pretty soon you're revealing your darker secrets. You know, I did futsal for a while and then netball. And even if these people don't become like your lifelong best friends, we know from numerous studies that just having that regular, social contact helps alleviate loneliness. There's really few feelings worse than realizing that you've gone days without speaking to anyone and we really want to avoid that. So if sport isn't your thing,
喜欢他们的朋友。而且，如果你知道他们也认识刚刚搬来的人，那就更棒了，因为他们也同样在寻找朋友。第二点是加入当地的社交运动小组。很容易交到朋友。你一周见他们一次。结束后你可以去喝一杯。你们进行社交，很快就会吐露你们内心深处的秘密。你知道的，我玩了一段时间的室内五人制足球，然后是无挡板篮球。即使这些人没有成为你一生的挚友，我们从大量研究中也知道，仅仅拥有那种规律的社交接触，就有助于缓解孤独感。没有什么感觉比意识到自己已经好几天没跟任何人说话更糟糕的了，我们真的要避免这种情况。所以如果运动不是你的菜，
I also think that things like art classes or pottery classes, just somewhere you can go for a discreet period of time on a regular schedule. My third tip is to try and keep a routine. Go to the gym at the same time. Go to the same cafes. or bars, catch the train at the same time, work from, you know, the office as much as possible because that is how you will often encounter the people with the same schedule as you and kind of bingo, you have something in common, you have something to talk about, you see them regularly, it's the easiest way to meet new people. A few more tips, I would say in that first six-month period, say yes to absolutely everything, even if you think that it's not your cup
我也觉得诸如艺术班或陶艺班之类的活动很好，只要是一个你可以按规律日程定期去一段时间的地方。我的第三个建议是尽量保持规律的作息。在相同的时间去健身房。去相同的咖啡馆或酒吧，在相同的时间坐火车，尽可能多地在办公室办公——因为这就是你经常能遇到和你作息相同的人的方式，然后，宾果！你们有了共同点，有了可以聊的话题，你们经常见面，这是结识新人的最简单途径。再多给几个建议，我想说在最初的六个月里，对绝对所有的事情都要说“好”，即使你认为那不是你的菜。
of tea. Join Bumble BFF. That is also a really big help when we're in a new city. And whatever you do, do not date within the first six months. You can go on the casual day. You can have a hookup, but finding a committed partner during this time is not going to do any good. And although it might feel nice to have someone you can rely on, I think it will most likely leave you feeling isolated because you don't build those connections for yourself. I actually spoke to this girl the other day who had just moved to Sydney and she had started dating someone like a month into being here and eight months later they broke up. But because all of her friends were his friends, she essentially had to start from scratch. So I think it's your time to feel a little bit scared to feel independent
下载 Bumble BFF。当我们身处新城市时，这也是一个巨大的帮助。无论你做什么，在头六个月内都不要谈恋爱。你可以去进行那种随意的约会。你可以有一夜情，但在这期间找一个坚定的伴侣对你没有任何好处。虽然身边有个可以依赖的人可能会感觉不错，但我认为这最有可能让你感到孤立，因为你没有为自己建立那些连接。我前几天跟一个刚搬到悉尼的女孩聊过，她在来到这里大约一个月时开始和某人约会，八个月后他们分手了。但因为她所有的朋友都是他的朋友，她基本上不得不从零开始。所以我认为这是你感受恐惧、感受独立并独自飞翔的时间。
and fly solo. Even if that leaves you feeling a little bit lonely at times, do not just jump into a new relationship for that sense of comfort. The other major factor is, of course, living situation. I don't know about you guys, but every city around Australia right now is facing a massive rental shortage, and landlords are just taking advantage of that, like, crazy. Like, I've seen friends have rental increases of upwards of, like, $200 a week, like, each. So the cost of living and finding a place to live is going to be difficult. I think it can be hard to feel settled if you feel uncomfortable or uncertain in your housing situation
即使这有时会让你感到有点孤独，也不要为了追求那种安全感而仓促投入一段新的感情。另一个主要因素当然是居住状况。我不知道你们的情况怎样，但现在澳大利亚的每个城市都面临着严重的租房短缺，房东们简直在疯狂地利用这一点。就像我看到朋友们的房租每周上涨高达200美元，每人都是如此。因此，生活成本和找地方住将会是很困难的。如果你对自己的住房状况感到不舒服或不确定，你可能会很难感到安定，
because like we said before, that security is one of our foundational needs. But here are some of the tips that you can bring with you. If you want to give yourself some time to find a place that you really love that is in your budget, I would totally suggest house sitting for the first month whilst you find your feet. often that also means you get free accommodation so good for saving money and you can actually take your time to find something perfect secondly share housing is kind of amazing for these situations because based on your luck with roommates you basically have inbuilt friends from the moment you move and they typically already have community that you can kind of access or slot right into also it's likely to be cheap
因为正如我们之前所说，安全感是我们最基础的需求之一。但这里有一些你可以借鉴的建议。如果你想给自己一些时间去寻找一个真正喜欢且在预算之内的房子，我完全建议你在站稳脚跟的第一个月里帮人看家。通常这意味着你可以获得免费住宿，这对省钱很有好处，而且你可以真正花时间去寻找完美的东西。其次，合租对于这种情况来说简直棒极了，因为根据你遇到室友的运气，你基本上从搬进去的那一刻起就有了现成的室友朋友，而且他们通常已经有了你可以融入或直接加入的社群。此外，它可能比较便宜，
and I know that living alone is so nice, but it's also a bit of a luxury and sometimes I do think that it can isolate us further when we come home from a long day at work and we kind of only have our bed or our TV to comfort us. It's not for everyone, but literally two of my housemates we met on Facebook, they had just moved to the city and they're legends and already they kind of feel like part of the family. Also around some of that financial uncertainty, I think, moving is inevitably going to cost you some money. There is no way around that, especially if you're moving overseas, things like visas, passport fees, extra luggage. It adds up, obviously. Financial anxiety can be a really significant stressor that interrupts the excitement of the experience. And we did a
而且我知道一个人住确实很好，但它也是一种奢侈，有时我确实认为，当我们结束一天漫长的工作回到家，身边只有床或电视来安慰我们时，它会让我们进一步与世隔绝。这并不适合所有人，但我的两个室友真的是我们在Facebook上认识的，他们刚搬到这座城市，简直是传奇人物，而且很快他们就感觉像是家人一样。此外，围绕着某种财务不确定性，我认为，搬家不可避免地会花掉你一些钱。这是无法避免的，特别是如果你要搬到海外，诸如签证、护照费、额外行李等费用。显然这些都会积少成多。财务焦虑可能会成为一个非常重大的压力源，打断这段经历的兴奋感。我们在大约一年前就这个话题做过一整期节目，
whole episode on this about a year ago about how stress around money can really manifest in our mental and emotional experiences. But basically, I would say before you move, try and have enough money saved up that you could feasibly cover three months of living expenses generously. Kind of see that fund not as an emergency fund but as a solution fund. If things don't work out as planned, if the job hunt or the house hunt is a bit harder than you expected, at least in that situation, you're not needing to stress from day one from the moment you get off the plane. You have a bit of time, a bit of a buffer to really sort everything out. my goodness, this is kind of turning into a financial podcast rather than a psychology podcast. I did
探讨了金钱方面的压力如何在我们的心理和情感体验中表现出来。但基本上，我想说的是，在你搬家之前，尽量存够一笔钱，足以游刃有余地支付三个月的生活开支。不要把这笔资金视为应急资金，而是要把它看作是解决方案资金。如果事情没有按计划进行，如果找工作或找房子比你预期的要难，至少在这种情况下，你不需要从下飞机的那一刻起就感到压力山大。你有一点时间，有一点缓冲来真正把一切都理顺。天哪，这怎么快变成一个金融播客而不是心理学播客了。我
not see that happening, but I think returning to that first point, my final piece of advice is to just give it time. This is such an exciting chapter in your life. I am excited for you if this is a choice that you're making. But also, it's not just the good, exciting bits that are important. It's also about the spectrum of emotions, the frustration, the loneliness, the fear, the displacement. Not every experience has to be a good experience and not every experience has to make you stronger, but I do think that they bring dimension into your life and also they bring you more to your personality, more to your personhood. What kind of people would we be if we never challenged ourselves? If we were never able to kind of take a chance, never just kind of took that leap of
完全没料到会这样，但回到最初的那一点，我给出的最后一条建议就是：给它一点时间。这是你人生中非常令人兴奋的一个篇章。如果你做出了这个选择，我为你感到兴奋。但同时，重要的不仅仅是那些美好、令人兴奋的部分。它还关于各种情绪的组合——沮丧、孤独、恐惧、流离失所。并不是每一次经历都必须是美好的经历，也不是每一次经历都必须让你变得更坚强，但我确实认为它们会为你的生活带来维度，也为你的个性和人格增添更多内涵。如果我们从不挑战自己，会成为什么样的人？如果我们从来不敢去冒险，从来不去盲目地信仰并付诸行动，仅仅是因为那是我们想为自己创造的未来。我真的由衷地认为，如果你有这个机会，这是一次极具变革性的经历，希望我为你提供了充分的证据来考虑它，同时也提供了一些让这种过渡变得更容易的方法。老实说，从我收到的所有评论来看，没有一个人后悔这个决定。所以，我想说的是，如果我们想要充分利用这十年，搬到一个新环境中，探索一座新城市，这似乎是一个非常强有力的竞争者，能真正帮助我们充分利用20多岁所能提供的一切。所以我真的希望你喜欢这期节目。我当然很喜欢。
faith and did it because we wanted to, because that is the future that we wanted to create for ourselves. I just really truly think that if you have this opportunity, it is such a transformative experience and hopefully I have given you some sufficient evidence to consider it, but also some of the ways that you can make that transition easier. Honestly, from all the comments I've received, there has not been a single person who has regretted this decision. So, I would say if we're looking to make the most out of this decade, moving, you know, putting ourselves in that new environment, exploring a new city, that seems like a pretty strong contender to help us really, I think, make the most out of everything that our 20s has to offer. So I really hope that you enjoyed this episode. I certainly did.
老实说，由于这也是我正在考虑做出的决定，一些研究对我来说真的非常有共鸣。我们绝对是在同一条船上。一如既往，如果你喜欢这期节目，请随时与你认为可能需要听听这期节目的朋友、爱人、家庭成员或同事分享。并在 Apple Podcasts、Spotify 或你现在收听的任何地方给我们留下五星好评。这确实对节目的成长和接触新听众非常有帮助。我们还有一个 Patreon。如果你喜欢我的内容，并且想要进一步支持我，这档节目真的全靠我一个人在做，
Honestly, some of the research was really validating for me, given that this is a decision that I'm also looking to make. We are in the same boat, that is for sure. As always, if you enjoyed this episode, please feel free to share it with a friend, a loved one, a family member, a co-worker who you think might need to hear this episode. And leave us a five-star review on Apple Podcasts, Spotify, wherever you are listening right now. It really does help the show to grow and reach new people. We also have a Patreon. And if you like my content and if you want to support me further, it really is just me doing
而且工作量很大。我显然非常热爱它。但如果你想获得更多内容、独家花絮等内容，请随时加入我们的 Patreon 以获得访问权限。至于节目建议，你可以直接在 Instagram 上私信我 @That Psychology Podcast。这是一期很有趣的节目。我真的希望你喜欢它。我绝对喜欢。我们下周将带着另一期节目回归。
this show and it's a lot of work. I obviously love it dearly. But if you want to get more content, bonus episodes behind the scenes, content as well, please feel free to join our Patreon to have access to that. And episode suggestions, you can direct them to me on Instagram at That Psychology Podcast. This is a fun episode. I really hope you enjoyed it. I definitely did. And we will be back next week with another episode. on the Look Back at it podcast For 1979 That was a big moment for me
欢迎收听 Look Back at It 播客，我是关于1979年的节目，对我来说那是一个大时刻
84 was big to me I'm Sam Jay And I'm Alex English Each episode We pick a year unpack what went down And try to make sense of how we survived it
1984年对我来说意义重大，我是 Sam Jay，我是 Alex English，每期节目我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的
With our friends fellow comedians And favorite authors Like Mark Lamont Hill On the 80s 84 was a wild I mean It was a wild year
与我们的朋友、同为喜剧演员以及最喜欢的作家们一起，比如 Mark Lamont Hill 在讨论80年代时，84年真是疯狂的一年，我的意思是，那是疯狂的一年
I don't think There's a more important year for black people Listen to look back at it On the IHeart Radio app Apple Podcasts Or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host, Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor? It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to.
我认为没有比这更重要的一年了，对于黑人来说，收听 Look Back at It 在 iHeart Radio app、Apple Podcasts 或任何你获取播客的地方。嘿，你们好吗？欢迎收听《The Hard Way》，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人 Kear Gaines。这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都无法真正安全进行的坦诚对话，但你是在和一个懂行的持证专业人士对话。有多少男人穿着一套盔甲？它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你必须这么做。
Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice in so-ins, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Ranini.
在 iHeart Radio app、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《The Hard Way》。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Eckerd）被指控生下双胞胎。但这次怀孕似乎是个骗局。你伪造了这个特定的测试两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。互联网侦探大军经过一番搜寻，揭露了一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士：格雷格·吉莱斯皮（Greg Gillespie）和迈克尔·拉尼尼（Michael Ranini）。
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available.
我的脑子炸裂了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《陷入爱河》（Love Trapped）。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于面临了后果。在 iHeart Radio app、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《陷入爱河》播客。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。
I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWA% on the I-HartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中培养心理韧性、健身和建立抗压能力的科学。让自己经历一些磨难，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更满足、更健康的人。收听《2%》。即 TWA%，在 iHeart Radio app、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方。这是一个 iHeart 播客。保证是人类制作。这集节目目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。